hey guys it is the 30th of June today
and you're watching games but news my
name is jeff mcdonald if you didn't know
already and that's all the boring
exposition out the way so let's get into
the good stuff it's not today of
Nintendo's Shigeru Miyamoto has said
that unlike other companies Nintendo has
trouble deciding what school me too did
me too the legendary designer said he
doesn't think it's as easy to sidle
Nintendo's games up the others
comparison because he sees them as their
own entity and genre he cited one of the
differences as a Nintendo really taking
its game seriously explaining it's not
that I don't like serious story for that
I couldn't make one but currently in the
video game industry you see a lot of
game designers who are working really
hard to make their game seem really cool
for a lot of us at Nintendo it's
difficult to decide what cool is in fact
it's a lot easier for us to laugh at
ourselves it's almost as if we're
performers our way of performing is by
creating these fun odd and creeping
things next up steam stats okay that's a
really boring way to start a story but
stick with me because I promise this is
pretty interesting so the pc gaming
service just hit a record of over 8
million concurrent users which is up
from the 7.6 million concurrent users
six months ago thanks to the stream
summer sale also because of steams
open-door policy with user data we know
what games are popular with its users
right now unsurprisingly daughter to
grab the top spot with over five hundred
and sixty-six thousand people playing
concurrently while the second most
popular is counter strike global
offensive which had almost ninety-five
thousand players getting stuck into the
shooting fun times let me know in the
comments which other games you think up
there on the most-played list are you
happy to sit on the sidelines and watch
xbox and playstation duke it out with
their consoles this holiday season as
they say they're expecting a pretty big
fight between the two publishers EA coo
peter moore told industry site games
industry international the competition
is
good for business and his humors he also
seven he thinks the ps3 and 360 will be
supported for another two or three years
and that EA will continue to make games
for those platforms as long as gamers
want them he praised how long Sony
extended life of the ps2 noting that he
was at Microsoft for the end of the Xbox
where they pretty much straight up
buried it due to poor sales and finally
a naughty dog death has called the last
of us on ps4 at 60 frames per second a
transformative experience designer Kurt
margon or tweeted played some the last
of us at 60 frames per second tonight
for the first time 60 frames per second
cutscenes and all transformative I'm a
believer don't think I can go back
co-director Bruce Straley and Neil
druckmann also had a Twitter
conversations that started with straily
saying I have a dream in 60fps last
night hashtag tlou vreemde losted
druckmann then replied what if I told
you that was no dream hashtag believe
the answer pretty subtle but I think we
can assume this means at 60 frames per
second Last of Us remastered is go as
always if you're playing along at home
be sure to let me know if you want to
play the last of us at 60 frames per
second or not that is it for me today
but tomorrow I'll be back same time with
even more new so I hope to see you then